i do want to spend a few minutes
covering the latest uh
rantings from former president donald
trump as we learned this weekend and as
we talked about on yesterday's show
donald trump is very much in control of
a huge portion of the republican party
and trump's agenda-setting power is
going to influence
how the republican party positions
itself for 2022 in 2022
hopefully joe biden can get much done
between now and november of 22.
uh but those second two years of joe
biden's presidency
are going to determine the legacy of the
administration in terms of the totality
of what gets done
now donald trump as you may know has a
blog
it was promoted as a new social media
communications platform
uh was going to be life-changing it was
revolutionary it turns out it's just a
blog
and the blog posts read like tweets so
this is kind of like
sad trump twitter as maybe we should
call it
and over the last 48 hours donald trump
has published multiple
screeds to sad trump twitter and if they
are any indication
about the likely direction and focus
of the republican party over the next
period of time
it's looking very humiliating and i'm
unclear whether there's a strategy here
at all
never mind a potentially winning
strategy so let's jump right in donald
trump's starting out
even sunday's mother's day turning it
into something political
saying happy mother's day to all it will
all come back
bigger and better and stronger than ever
before do not worry
now the economy is doing uh
as well as it has done throughout the
entire pandemic
new stock market records inflation
remains low
vaccination is doing well biden's
popularity
63 more than half the country thinks
we're going in the right direction so
trump is teasing that someday we'll get
back to things being good
things have improved dramatically since
donald trump left
from then trump going on to tweet sorry
to blog about the kentucky derby but
very late
saying so now even our kentucky derby
winner medina spirit
is a junkie j-u-n-k-y now that's
yeah anyway that that's the wrong
spelling but that's fine this is
emblematic of what is happening to our
country the whole world is laughing at
us as we go to hell
on our borders our fake presidential
election he's still
going with that and everything else
then trump attempting to weigh in on
the liz cheney situation once again and
this relates to that pro
versus anti-trump split in the
republican party that we talked about in
some detail yesterday
trump saying quote the house gop has a
massive opportunity
to upgrade this week from war monger liz
cheney
to gifted communicator elise stefanik
elise has intelligence an endorsement
from
american patriot brandon judd and the
national border patrol council
she has an a-plus from the nra and she
loves
our veterans we need someone in
leadership who has experience
flipping districts from blue to red as
we approach
the important 2022 midterms and that's
elise
she knows how to win which is what we
need now the theme
here is cancel
those who aren't on message with the
republican party
these people claim to be against
cancellation and yet
they are very quickly going to cancel
romney cancel liz cheney
uh and trump wanting to play king maker
for 2022
then trump issuing sort of like a
political endorsement also part of this
he wants to play king maker narrative
saying quote lieutenant governor dan
patrick is a great fighter for the
people of texas
he has stood up for life liberty the
second amendment
border security our military and our
vets and our
god-given freedoms he is governed by
conservative principles of low taxes and
careful spending
always doing what is best for his great
state and for america
texas should re-elect him he is
outstanding and has my complete and
total endorsement now dan patrick is one
of the most disgusting
uh state level officials up there
with greg abbott from texas and you know
so many others christy gnome and
and so many others he's the guy who
early in the pandemic said listen
uh grandma would sacrifice herself for
the economy
by which he met the stock market and uh
it went downhill from there so trump
already aligning his endorsements in
there of the worst
most horrible people then trump going
after mitt romney continuing the
republican party split saying after
being loudly booed at the utah
republican party convention
utah's weber county censured rhino
mitt romney in the strongest of terms
washington county republicans
also censured romney in april he is bad
news
for our country clearly trump
will be involved in the 2022 election
and then lastly
another one of these delusional election
fraud posts trump writing
the major michigan election fraud case
has just
filed a bombshell no they haven't
pleading
claiming votes were intentionally
switched
from president trump to joe biden the
number of votes is massive and
determinative
this will prove true in numerous other
states all republicans must unify and
not let this happen
if a thief robs a jewelry store of all
its diamonds
the 2020 election the diamonds must be
returned
the fake news media refuses to cover
the greatest election fraud in the
history of our country
they have lost all credibility but
ultimately they will have no choice
so he's still going and we could write
it off as just delusions
but most of the republican party still
believes it
they still believe joe biden didn't
really win
the 2020 election so the question is
can this work to win them 2022
it lost them to the house in 2018 it
lost them the senate in 2020
it lost them the white house in 2020.
can it work
in 2022 or is it destined
to give them the same disaster let me
know what you think we are doing a
one-day huge membership special
on memorial day uh wanna be notified
it's very easy
just get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
on memorial day a glorious day you will
get an email telling you exactly how to
take advantage
of this incredible one-day membership
special we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this it means you're not
going to be charged when you don't want
to be because you can destroy the
virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com slash pacman